I also want to kind of segue into a EA's
pivot recently with visceral came up
yesterday I believe on click soul I was
Brian Corsetti the first one just uh
that published something about the
patent that Activision filed back in
2015
yeah I'm not really so let me let me
pull this up right um let me fill you in
so the headline field LIXIL was
Activision researched using matchmaking
tricks to sell in-game items basically
using players as advertisers right so as
they described it here's the if you're
watching live right now or on youtube
you could see the article right here
again this is by Brian Corsetti over at
clicks alluring stones gaming site
Activision was granted a patent this
month for a system it uses to convince
people in multiplayer games to purchase
items for a game through
microtransactions Activision did tell
Glick so that the technology is not
currently in any game so to clarify just
for be or purpose purposes I think we'll
have Call of Duty World War two up any
number of Activision titles but again
just to double down this system is not
in use in any current activision games
that they told Glick cyl but and Bungie
also confirmed the Glacial that the
technology is not being used in destiny
- but to describe the system it
essentially like you just said was that
you or you Pete you just said that they
kind of use I say that was you know use
me a better player say a better player
kills you it's almost like you mentioned
in a battle front - you were saying like
if like a TIE fighter blows you up and
then you see that has three legendary
cards this system essentially has the
capability to purposely pair you with
very very good players with good loot to
encourage you to be like ah [ __ ] I feel
like I'm missing out I feel like I'm
it's not a level playing field it will
purposely pair you with marquee players
according to the wording in the patent
first of all you can get jealous yes yes
and then you'll feel the need to pay so
according to Activision in the patent it
says for example in one implementation
the system may include a micro
transaction engine that arranges matches
to influence game related purchases for
instance the micro transaction engine
may match a more expert slash marquee
player with a junior player and to
encourage that junior player to make
game early
purchases of items possessed or used by
the marquis slash expert player a junior
player may a junior player may wish to
emulate that player by obtaining weapons
or other items used by that player so it
was what you were afraid of with
Battlefront - if you said they're
showing that's what that's what
battlefront - I can't you know we can't
say that battlefronts who implements
this system but on the chant in the case
that a much better player kills you and
you see they have three legendary cards
that's essentially what would happen
with the system except on purpose on the
game's exactly it's like an algorithm
like this this could happen right now
with so many games yeah well yeah this
is this article is just or this patent
is saying that like we're gonna enforce
it which is crazy think cuz it's so
counterintuitive yeah where so many
games have been frustrating like I think
one example I can't remember but like
titanfall kind of had this problem where
I felt like I was getting consistently
paired up with like really good players
and hope you know you'd like to think
the next match will be okay you kind of
played like [ __ ] let's put you with some
other shitty people like yeah but you
would have really good matchmaking soon
as splatoon implements that pretty well
yeah unless you're playing with like a
friend who's really high level then you
might get your ass kicked but but that's
all isn't that aesthetic stuff
this is platoon mainly cosmetic it I
mean it the emphasis is on looking good
I think in splatoon but you do have
specific abilities and it'll tell you
what you got killed I mean a lot of
games tell you what you got killed with
yeah like that's that's not new at all
um the problem here is that it's the it
would be on purpose to to make you buy
something but I guess like I mean
honestly like normally when I play a
game and I see what I got killed with
I'm like oh so that's the meta weapon
that's the weapon everybody's using like
in destiny it's like Oh everyone's using
Uriel's gift or whatever
maite right yeah so but you can get that
without buying it and it's not like it's
gonna be like ah we only put my two
players in this match oh man hey do you
think you need mighta to be good I'll
see ya I'll say it again like oh man
when path front comes out and God like
if that's gonna be the first thing that
happens the first person that kills me
is
it's a guy flying by in the next wing
with three legendary cards he's like so
I feel like peace out and I haven't even
gotten the slots yet to have cards like
yeah it would be annoying and make you
jealous
Activision yeah Activision told Glick
soul this was an exploratory patent
filed in 2015 by an R&D team working
independently from our game studios it
has not been implemented in game there's
one more example that they kind of the
patent mentioned let me see in a
particular example the junior player may
wish to become an expert sniper in a
game for example as determined from the
player profile according to the patent
the microchip microtransaction engine
may match the junior player with a
player that is a highly skilled sniper
in the game in this manner the junior
player may be encouraged to make game
related purchases such as a rifle or
other item used by the Marquis sniper
player so that's getting into like
really many gritty stuff like based on
your loadouts across this profile we
know you want to be good at sniping so
we're gonna use that and again this
isn't being user now but this is like a
what essentially saying it could be used
for we know you want to be a good sniper
so we're gonna use that to promote
certain items to you and also put you in
it also says that they could potentially
be put in game types or on maps that
also are very sniper friendly or like
why not just get good yeah it's really
frustrating when like winning only it
seems or feels like you would be good if
only you've had a certain weapon right
whereas like I know like we just used
the mighta example in destiny but people
like going with green basic ass weapons
and they do well and it's about skill
and that's something that I liked about
the crucible a lot is that you don't
technically need those things and it
actually like I've been killed by super
basic weapons and I was like okay I
guess I me doing that might a quest
wasn't the only thing I needed to do to
win and the idea that like the thing
that upsets me most about this patent
besides the like targeted ads basically
within the game that you already bought
the idea that this game the it fits a
certain kind of game design that would
make it so you needed the correct leader
to win which just just irritates me that
just irks me it's like it's not a skill
at all it's something I always assumed
and I'm not shocked that this exists
it's something I assumed was happening
but now like you see on Facebook
obviously it targeted ads across well
anytime you're on yes it's it's not
shocking to see games using it but it's
just seeing the actual patent and
reading it in the patents words and what
Activision said two clicks Allah the
thing I want from now you're now you're
further thinking about it yes that's
what is like the frustrating part of all
the things that we always suspect is
that right the publishers mindset when
it comes to a video game has changed so
dramatically that it's become about this
sort of subtle manipulation versus
funding a great game I mean it's not
news that games are a bigger business
than ever and they're trying to you know
make more money but this is sort of is
like yeah I mean that's this is it on
paper
this is them saying that it exactly it's
a it's like owning up to it I mean
because like games being designed in a
way to make more money is it dates back
to arcades I mean that's not like a new
thing I mean making a game can be more
difficult to you some money on this is
like weird like manipulation well I'm
just saying like this we know that's we
know that's not new Rus is like a
different level of like like a good
arcade game can be made difficult but
made difficult in a way that compels you
to want to keep playing exactly it's not
just like oh I died so I feel like I
need to put more money in this right
this is to a different sort of pad in my
mind is a different path I mean that's
what I was getting at it's like to feel
like oh I need to buy something to get
better because no matter how how much I
practice or how much I put into
improving my skill is not going to
matter that's basically what I was
getting at yeah my last question before
we get onto visceral Pete this in
addition to things with shadow of war
recently force a seven what I'm missing
battlefront two which we spoke about
last week on a la beat does this kind of
worry you that again like you just
mentioned this this very well could be
stuff like this is probably being used
in games already but the fact that now
we just see it in writing
does this kind of worry you about stuff
going forward and worries it makes me
worry for the people who really like
these sort of games yeah I I'm not huge
into multiplayer competitive stuff like
all the time so I can easily walk away
from something like this I got plenty of
games with like excellent stories that I
can't wait to interact with things like
that so for me personally I don't think
I'm ever going to run out of good games
to play mm-hmm but I do think it is a
problem that will affect a lot of people
and will have a negative impact if this
is a directive that is sort of seen
through and taken to its logical
conclusion it it worries me when I think
about like a 12 year old I think I said
last time like someone that's that's
literally like my main concern is like
there's just thirst you know you're 10
you're 12 like you don't own a house you
don't like no pay rent you don't have a
job maybe it's maybe it's your mom's
credit cards but like there are there
are going to be cases where it's it's
just a kid or someone who is it hasn't
you know experienced Libran up to like
manage money like just realize what this
is at face value right right like
understand the emotions that they're
feeling and why exactly my little
brother would have if this had been
around when he was 12 I mean he would
have spent so much money on this and it
would have been a huge problem like I
know that for a fact and luckily he's
just he just missed that because he's
adult now I mean if you're like 21 right
now you have you could have disposable
income to spend on this stuff - yeah and
if you're like even if you know better
yeah cuz maybe you're you know you're in
college you don't really pay your own
rent in full yet stuff like that you
don't really understand how much money
you start justifying cuz it's you know
at best things it's just a dollar it's
just so it's just a couple dollars and
I'm you know for a battlefront like I
said last time like if there's their
hats now well I think they actually
resigned that thought
remember earlier out saying oh because
one of the early systems they said was
the legendary the best cards in the game
the legendre is you can only open or get
in a loot crate but so I think they're
pulling that back I guess what I'm
saying is like hey if I'm guaranteed a
legendary in this loot crate that's a
win-win that's a dollar
cool right like how many and then it's
like well all
yet a couple more it wasn't like you
know my favorite card I mean I'm looking
for a TIE fighter so maybe but it $30
$20 I don't know over the course of a
couple months like yes $1 you know a
dollar day to go back to the Taco Bell
example of last week just think about
how many tacos you could buy with all of
those dollars you're spending and like
right now opposed to like you know
milking a cow and making own cheese hey
you can this taco can be yours for free
but you got to make everything yourself
so right around back here's old Bessie
here's old Bessie yeah no not old Bessie
here's a baby calf that you need to
first apologies farmers out there um and
cows and cows and Taco Bell I don't know
the thing is people are saying like do
you think this will stop anytime soon
and I was wondering maybe the press is
getting bad enough that Warner Brothers
or Activision or EA will stop it but
holy [ __ ] they make a lot of money off
it dude and people are growing up on
these kind of games so in like in 10
years it could be the norm and like
where people were just those people you
know those old people on the porch
yelling again they can't like think
about like just like your typical
teenagers playing like are they really
you know digging deep into like
criticisms of games like they know
they're gonna get it the call of duty
they like a Star Wars fan is gonna get
battlefront yeah blank card need to buy
this gun card and like you said memorize
the number they like you there is a rut
like that's why yeah they're like
another part of it is like there is that
rush you get when you get that cool item
by chance like its euphoric like if you
don't realize you're having that I mean
this is enabling you're gonna go in a
lot of you're gonna keep not playing
yeah games I'm just kidding
hey that's super I just the thing that
bothers me is like yeah these things are
going to make money but not everything
that makes a lot of money has been
moral or goodbye society and it just it
just was so disheartening to me because
it's like when that's the thing that
determines when money is the thing that
determines everything I'm just like all
right well I like art yeah so the
frigate spinners are pretty cool though
I know but realistically they're pretty
cool
[Music]